هذه هي كتدرائيه القديسات الصوفيه التي
بنيت في النصف الاول من القرن الحادي عشر
في وسط العاصمه كيف
الكاتدرائيه تمثل النصب لمعماريه
والثقافيه الرئيسيه للعاصمه الاوكرانيه مع
اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا تم اغلاقها مع
القليل من المتاحف والكاتدرائيه في
الاقاليم لكن مع سد الهجوم الروسي على كيف
اعيد افتتاحها شهر مايو الماضي
لدينا في الكاتدرائيه كانت توجد كهرباء
وانترنت والناس الذين لجاوا الينا في
المعبد او في مساحه الكاتدرائيه ظل هنا
يعملون بعد هجمات الجيش الروسي على البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا عانت العاصمه
كبقيه المدن الاوكرانيه من انقطاع مستمر
للتيار الكهربائي ففتحت الكاتدرائيه
ابوابها للمواطنين كمال
تتوفر فيه الكهرباء والدفء في مساحات
واماكن عمل مريحه ومشروبات ساخنه واتصالات
وانترنت حيث يمكن لاهالك القدوم لاداء
اعمالهم
اعتقد ان هذا امرا ايجابيا اضافيا فبن
الرائع ان تجلس خلف الكمبيوتر وتنظر من
خلف النافذه الى معبد القديس صوفيا
وجمالها الخلاب
الجو العام رائع فهنا يوجد هدوء وهذا مهم
ففي الوقت الراهن ايجاد مكان هادئ ومريح
صعب جدا
هذا مهم جدا لان لدينا اجتماعات نقوم بها
عبر الانترنت مع عملائنا في الدول
الاوروبيه
لعده قرون المركز الروحيه لاوكرانيا فقط
ولكن اي مركز الدبلوماسيه والعلوم هنا حتى
امراءوكيين عقدوا اجتماعاتهم مع السفراء
الاجانب الان تعمل صوفيا كمتحف ولكن بسبب
القصف ونقص الكهرباء عادها الاوكرانيون
الى سابق عهدها والاداره تقول انه اذا احب
الناس مكان العمل هنا فيمكنهم تركه حتى
بعد الحرب حذيف عادل العرب العربيه